white house correspondent peter ducey
starts us off live on the north lawn
good evening peter good evening brett
people waiting for prices to go down are
going to have to wait a while because
white house officials are saying that
prices are going to moderate over the
course of 2022. the year that just
started and around here they are
conceding that projections about the
economy recovering from the pandemic
were off
when it comes to something like the
supply chain challenges
those manifested more significantly than
people were anticipating prices are up
up up 7 percent higher last month
compared to december 2020 rising at the
fastest rate since 1982. it's a
multi-pronged challenge searching for a
silver lining white house officials are
making this point wages are growing for
people at the bottom republicans have a
counterpoint even though people's wages
are have gone up their wage gains are
being wiped out by this inflation as
inflation increases the president's
approval falls to just 33 percent in a
new quinnipiac poll down from 36 percent
in november biden has claimed for months
this is a priority my laser focus is on
growing the nation's economy
and creating jobs but the hashtag bare
shelves biden has trended recently as
supply chain issues persist they don't
care that store shelves are empty in
fact they've denied that the store
shelves are actually empty that includes
the shelves carrying at home covered
tests in many places all of this covered
so-called covert relief the money didn't
go for testing where it was supposed to
go and whatever happened to the website
where the white house says people can
request some of the 500 million free
at-home tests the website should be
available should be online by this
weekend thomas inglesby is on leave from
johns hopkins and will now be the white
house testing czar in charge of
coordinating all those free tests
once they've been ordered the contracts
are just closing
today in the next couple of days after
nearly a year in office the
administration may also mail people and
95 or k and 95 masks right now we're
strongly considering
options to make more high quality masks
available to all americans so they're
trying something new even as the
president insists the country is on the
right track i would say we've made a
great deal of progress in the last few
weeks
and tomorrow we're told to expect an
update from president biden about the
white house's covet 19 response and
we'll be listening to see if he's
updating the language that he uses
remember it started out as we're going
to shut down the virus and then i
recently asked him whatever happened to
that and he said well we have to beat it
back before we shut it down but in the
weeks since colvin 19 has spread faster
than ever brett peter ducey live on the
north lawn peter thanks hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else